so a lot of times when we hear the word
net worth all we think about is money oh
that guy's net worth is 50 million 200
million three million 600 000 because we
measured based on money but we don't
think about how does somebody increase
their net worth well you need to write
relationships how do you get the right
relationship to the level of depth with
the connection and value for it to turn
into the kind of network that you have
today so all of this goes into think
about the five most valuable
relationships you have in your life
today think about those five you may say
wife a husband you know friend partner
business part whatever it is before they
became as valuable as they are today to
be in your five what caused it to get to
that level when you first met him okay
so go back 10 years ago 20 years ago
eight years ago three years ago what
happened for them to be in your top five
we're going to talk about that today and
by the way if we get value from this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let me get right into it
so we see Tom Brady and Gronk oh my God
they're so great together I bet they've
been best friends since day one they've
probably never had friction look at
Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett what a
great partnership Man Steve Jobs and
Johnny I phenomenal relationship Tim
Duncan and Popovich Inside the NBA TNT
shot Barkley Kenny Smith these guys are
phenomenal together what we don't see
behind closed doors how did these
relationships get into how it is today
this is what is going to happen 100 of
the time when a relationship gets deeper
is when they overcome friction together
okay friction is a byproduct of great
deeper relationships here's what happens
one time the New England Patriots
practice off season all these medias
their next thing you know the biggest
fight breaks up biggest fight breaks out
everybody's talking about oh my God the
New England Patriots are off to a bad
start there's a lot of infighting going
on practice ends media goes to Bill
Belichick so Bill you know what do you
need to do to unify this team it seems
like everybody's fighting each other
this is the worst we've ever seen the
Patriots going into the season how are
you going to fix this he says fix what
all the infighting he says if we're this
competitive against each other I feel
sorry for their opponents I'm what
they're going to do to them because this
is getting them to be closer and Tighter
Bill Belichick understood you need
friction to get the team to be closer
together sometimes
there's many stories where great coaches
create accidental friction to create a
bond within the team this has happened
many there's many stories I don't need
to go into your every one of the
friendships and relationships I talk
about today it'll come down to this but
here's the kicker when you go through it
you'll learn a lot about everybody
you'll learn how you handle friction
you'll learn how your approach is your
approach a good approach during times of
friction you'll learn if the other
person is willing and values their
relationship like I don't give a [__] I
don't know no problem and there's no
value the verse is saying no I listen
I'm not happy here's a conversation dot
dot dot but man I want to make this work
because I want to be in business with
you long term because I want us to be
friends long term because I want to be
with you long term we got to figure this
thing out but there's a moment of
friction here one night that's three
o'clock in the morning I'm with Mario in
the Rolls-Royce this is the story he
always tells this was a very awkward
moment of friction that he told it in
one of his videos that he did where he
was going through a certain challenge we
had this one moment together that could
have been the last day we him and I ever
worked together it's a very very
sensitive moment of friction that we
have to get it there's another guy was
in business I've been in business for a
long time one day I asked him to meet me
at the Northridge uh parking lot and we
had a three-hour conversation together
that was friction but I have to tell him
what I was on my mind and I said you
don't need to agree with anything I said
I just want you to hear me out give me
three hours I'll never say to you ever
again you'll be left alone that led to a
moment of breakthrough he and I shared
that moment together there's another guy
can tell a story about we're in Lake
Tahoe one time something happened to his
family we're in the theater room of this
house that had rented and he's in tears
Crown I've seen this guy cry five times
and I watched him and I said man this
guy's going through it right now there
was friction there was challenges in
order for relationships to get deeper
running mate spouse father son mom
daughter father daughter it doesn't
matter you and your mom or dad that only
happens when you guys go through a
moment of friction but both parties are
willing to get through that moment and
understanding together if you can do
that and have mutual respect while we're
doing this what she don't know that's
happening on a Leader's bulletin
statistically that relationship went
from a level one to a level two and a
half three months so you guys
experienced something again you just
went from a two and a half you overcame
that you go to 4.2 next time you have
another friction together this time it
wasn't handled well you go for a 2.8
next time you go through it again yeah I
don't give a [__] you go to 1.7 that's
exactly how these things are happening
so in my life I have a lot of valuable
relationships some I was in the military
I realized which one of my friends were
actually fully wanting to have a
long-term relationship to them for the
rest of my life I'm going to pour into
those guys that did what they did for me
I never forget in 1997 I'm in the
military I'm all by myself and I'm I had
all these friends that I thought were
like very very close friends are also
you go military comebacks man that guy
was a friend and he was with me through
thick and thin that I would never guess
she would have been there him
unbelievable but you almost need those
times to realize who has your back it's
unfortunate it's painful it's crazy but
it is a filtering process that's
required to go through times of friction
so anyways if this was a message you
needed to hear for you to realize maybe
you just went through a friction in a
relationship that maybe you didn't
handle the right way if you really value
that relationship great relationship or
very very very hard very very hard to
come across if you had a moment like
that maybe you ought to make a phone
call set aside your ego okay so I gotta
make that one work or if you're on the
complete opposite side
you gotta say you know this is somebody
that's really making an effort I want to
sit down and have a conversation with
these guys and actually tell them how I
didn't like this thing was handled and
hash it out because say I know this
person wants good for me I know this is
somebody that I love to have in my life
for the next 10 20 30 years let me make
that phone call once again just like in
life great opportunities don't come
along all the time they're only going to
come across a handful of times great
friendships and relationship and
business relationships oh my God they
don't come across all the time water
them value them protect them very hard
to find once again if you got value from
the video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel got another
video I want you to watch as well I did
a video six seven years ago titled how
to choose great friends if you've never
seen this video click here to watch it
take care everybody bye bye-bye
[Music]